four  ah yes  okay  we've got this is what we have so knight  h4 probably what bishop d4 or  bishop d4 check  okay oops oops oops  thanks rook g5 bye bye  oh  what devastating loss for arya and tary  yeah and what chances he had yeah we we  have to go back and check out that  position this position  how i didn't like rookie three i think  rook e3 is something that you don't have  time for okay so i wanted to go knight  g5 here  knight g5  and then  why why did they play knight g5 i don't  know maybe there's some pawn takes pawn  but i guess but it's ponte spawn then  f6  and that's a disaster so that's not  going to be satisfactory um any other  moves that black can try  um for instance the bishop coming out  too oh bishop b4 let's see no but bishop  d4 pawn takes porn uh sorry i have to be  clear it takes f7  you also have e takes f7